Ronnie said to us that he washes his ass
in the sink which is the road comes out
of the shower and has to go he doesn't
get back in the shower yes
Ronnie so just demo this for me okay
what's the deal go over there I'm going
the hell you want me to do
sure we got a sink let's get something
straight okay yeah this is like an
emergency thing it's not like something
I do every [ __ ] day took a shovel one
you turn number two when you take a
shower and you're washing [ __ ] out of
your ass into the shower it's going in
the bathtub on your feet or in the
shower but I don't do that all right
people who take a bath who just took a
[ __ ] this sitting in it okay yeah but
you nobody puts their I don't you don't
have to defend all right okay we have a
sink it's all set up take off my jacket
go ahead yeah naked man yeah I'm not
getting naked so you could forget that
[ __ ] this is why we don't let you in the
Illuminati cuz you wash your ass in the
sink as much time as you can take as
much time so right I wipe my ass go
ahead real good go ahead all nice and
clean right all right wipe my ass real
good right this is only an emergency all
right we get it okay all right now just
show me how you sit on this side so you
get up on the sink yeah remember I wipe
my ass already it's nice and clean right
so I'm just washing the remnants the
remnants out all right that's it what do
you do with your hands
what do you mean when I do it now what
do you do like you do you splash the
water in there do you know yeah I washed
my hand my wash my ass out and there's
the with the soap and with soap and
water not just some what [ __ ] my hand
yeah how do you get the water do you
think is running so your ass into the
sink no it's just like I'm sitting man
just like this and show me what you're
doing and don't know what is running
here's the water and you you wash your
ass
and you [ __ ] take it down you draw
your Arab quarter in the ball is there a
no no no no no the water is just running
I see okay okay all right that's it
that's the whole thing you had to buy a
sink for that Wow
so you wouldn't you go to pick out a
thing do you hop up on it to see if you
know this actually this one's small man
long you have a bar of this soap that
you uses from the bar of soap that sits
on the sink right yeah yeah yeah and
then you and then you just lean it I
wash my hands and everything afterwards
everything's cool oh so if I do the same
thing if you're in the bathtub taking a
bad I don't know how people take baths I
think that's the most unhealthy [ __ ]
thing ever
he's worried about health all right
thank you all right we got the bike sick
do I get [ __ ] disease just no there
you go there is Ronnie I never would
have occurred to me to do that good for
you all right the only one who does it
I guarantee it Oh people just won't
[ __ ] admit to it never heard of it
okay all right bless you